I want to show you guys how these evil
leaders be they people like Bill Gates
who have no right to have any control
over your life whatsoever
or Justin Trudeau who I would also argue
has no right to have any control over
your life but he is the prime minister
of a country they do have some Authority
I will accept that uh how they're bad
ideas are so easily shot down when
confronted with reality so this is an
Incredible video from yesterday this is
Scottish first Minister her name is
Nicola sturgeon and she is confronted
about the phrase trans women are women
relative to where trans women should go
to jail this one is a pure joy you will
not need your barf bag so wipe up your
mouth enjoy my question is are all trans
women women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with the question trans
women are women but in the present
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where a
trans woman is not a woman no that is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the
a woman born as a woman will be housed
in the real estate look we're talking
here about trans women I'm now asking
about women born as women I don't think
that our circumstances there but it's
different for trans women well yes and
I'm not so they're not equal that is not
that that is a risk assessment process
done for trans women that takes account
of the nature of the crime it clearly it
sets significant concern arises out of
sexual crime and whether it's
appropriate for them to be in a female
prison or a male person isn't it great
when these people are confronted with
reality like good job by that journalist
and I always say it's very refreshing
when I can actually say the word
journalist and not use air quotes trans
women are not women they are trans women
and again if you were an adult and you
choose to live your life as the opposite
sex if you really believe that is within
you and you want to put on a dress or
have whatever surgeries
I am and I don't understand I'm all for
it but but live go do your thing go do
your thing I I have no right to tell you
how to live your life as a autonomous
functioning adult but when you listen to
these people so trans women or women
well okay should they be in the women's
prison
well like well you can see and they
don't know what they're saying and it's
like uh okay well here's this trans
woman her name's Laura she's six foot
eight she just with her giant penis just
raped 18 girls
some of them under age we're going to
throw them in the chicken
what do you think we're doing over here
so these people when confronted with
reality their ideas this is one of the
reasons they're always going for
censorship why why are the lefties and
the walksters always trying to censor
people well it's a powerful tool like
it's just it's just powerful in and of
itself but also if your ideas are really
bad the best way you could keep pushing
them out there is to silence all dissent
and their ideas are terrible their ideas
you could poke through them easier than
poking through a wet paper bag that's
where we're at at the moment
[Music]
foreign